joined by Dr Rahul Gupta who is director
of the office for National Drug control
policy is responsible for coordinating
drug policy in the United States so Dr
Gupta thank you very much for your time
and thank you for being with us this
evening 70
000 deaths a year the biggest killer of
people aged 18 to 49 children dying kids
dying daily as Mark just told us why is
the US government failing to protect its
citizens and its children from fentanyl
well let's first uh talk about why this
is happening it's happening because we
lack a uh continuous treatment
infrastructure prediction it's happening
because the traffickers are continuing
to profit out of in a dispassionate way
out of vulnerable Americans and that's
exactly from day one President Biden has
been focused on and what we are trying
to do is build an addiction treatment
infrastructure while going after the
trafficking and the profits and we're
making some some of the most historic
progress as you talk about about harm
reduction expanding treatment and then
making sure that we're going after the
bad guys to hold them accountable I mean
but all of that is going to do nothing
for the parents of that 15 year old in
Kyle Texas who's just died from an
overdose because of this stuff
that's exactly right and you know I have
children I'm a parent I'm also a
physician somebody who has himself
attended funerals of people and sobbed
part of the reason is that we don't want
this to happen we want to make sure that
my own high school now I'm seeing
overdoses in the Washington area it is
important that we meet where young
people are make sure that they are aware
of the dangers of getting pills that are
not from a pharmacy or from a doctor and
make sure that they're carrying naloxone
or Narcan that's exactly what we're
doing when we put out a social media
campaign from the White House without
Council to make young people aware of
these dangers the fact is today that
ordering a pill online whether it's
Adderall or Xanax or anything the
counterfeit nature of that is more
dangerous than playing russial roulette
with your life and we want to make sure
that every young person Across America
is aware of that yeah it's important
that message gets out some 46 billion
dollars has been assigned to try and
fight this issue how much of that is
going towards stopping it coming across
the border and how much of that is going
into that treatment prevention
infrastructure you talked about
yeah that's a good question we have
about 57 of this is going towards
treatment and rest is going towards
addressing the supply side and what
we're trying to do is two things first
making sure we have a plan what we do
now we're seeing about eight months of
flattening or decrease in these historic
numbers we get we're not there we have a
long way to go secondly we're trying to
make sure that the world Community knows
that this is the synthetic issue is a
global threat there's three types of
countries in this world right now today
unfortunately one those who have a
synthetic drugs like fentanyl problem
and know about it like United States
others who have a problem don't yet know
about it and the third category is those
who are going to have this problem in
the future of synthetic drugs this has
really become a global Menace and it's
really important for United States as we
are doing to lead on this effort because
the trafficking is becoming more
internationalized as well yeah and I'm
glad that you have touched on that Dr
Gupta whether the UK fall in those
categories do you think we've got a
synthetic drug problem now we don't know
about it or is it coming
well first of all we know that uh you
know I've met with them my colleagues
and counterparts in the UK uh there's
obviously opioids problem like heroin
and others uh but is will not be a
surprise that it also become Falls
victim to a synthetic problem and that
is why
um you know my counterparts in the UK
are very active in supporting working
with the United States as are many other
countries across the globe to move
forward to make sure that we are taking
proactive steps not only reactive but
proactive steps to both have
surveillance monitoring but also then
denying the profits that these
trafficking organizations survive on
both operating capital and profits we
deny them both in order to beat this uh
particular crisis
okay Dr Rahel group to do appreciate
your time and expertise thank you very
much for being with us thank you